here are the seven yonko in one piece  former yonko include Whitebeard the  strongest man in the world he was one of  Roger's greatest Rivals and he possessed  the Tremor Tremor fruit big mom the only  female Yanko she had 85 children and she  possessed the soul soul fruit kaido was  the ruthless leader of the Beast Pirates  and the owner of the fish fish fruit  model Azure Dragon current yonko include  Shanks the man who inspired Luffy to  become a pirate he once served on  Roger's crew and he is the only Uncle  without a confirmed devil fruit  Blackbeard the only known person who is  able to use two different devil fruits  including the dark dark fruit and the  Tremor Tremor fruit which he stole from  Whitebeard buggy who also served on  Roger's crew and who possesses The Chop  Chop fruit and Luffy our protagonist and  the user of the human human fruit model  Nika subscribe for more one piece